I am wearing Princess Peach's suit biker
suit made by Christian Dior
which is kind of crazy yeah how long
have you had this planned has this been
made for a while because it is epic well
when we started doing it I kind of said
that I would come in Cosplay and I felt
like I had to keep that promise and I
just feel so lucky that Dior wanted to
make it because it's awesome we are so
grateful for you
um tell me about this I want to know who
wins in a Mario Kart Contest out of the
lead cast in this movie who wins Jack
Black
I've heard I've heard he's kind of like
a menace at it yeah
yeah I think I think he kind of went
hands down were you a big Mario fan
coming into this or was it a whole new
world an environment you were learning
about it was a whole new world I was
obviously hyper aware of it but I just
never played the game and I got to play
the game as research which was kind of
the greatest homework I've ever had for
a role so I'll take it again Bowser is
coming
together we
are going to stop that monster how look
at us we're horrible now you're our
Princess Peach and I'm Never Gonna Let
You Go I love what you did with the
voice did you have to exercise in any
certain direction to come up with a
voice for princess
originally I wanted to keep it closer to
what it was in the video game and then I
realized that with the script that was
written that just wasn't going to work
she had way more colors than that so I
had so much fun with the creators just
playing around and hopefully having that
range makes her a bit more 3D
they're all counting on us hello
no pressure do you feel any nerves about
turning out a project like this there
are so many Die Hard Super Mario
Brothers fans out there and now you are
a princess and you did such a great job
I got to see it last week but do you
feel any nerves about delivering this to
this audience you know my brain does
this strange thing where it doesn't let
me freak out about anything whilst I'm
doing it it only happens once it's done
and I can't do anything about it so
right now yes whilst it's happening no
which I'm grateful for but now yeah kind
of
I love how your mind works it works
great how about this one should there be
a Princess Peach spin-off we would all
be happy I'm sure would you be up for
doing something like that absolutely I
had such a good time everyone's so kind
it's wonderful to meet everybody in
person
um yeah I'm down for every Adventure
I'll let you run away but tell me what's
the best thing about this experience
making such a movie that so many people
are gonna love so many young people and
you're gonna be the face of that I think
it's the fact that they're going to grow
up with this being female leadership
with Princess Peach being a role model I
left the film feeling really inspired
and quite emotionally moved
[Music]
thank you